[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday july 7th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
cloud computing has become an essential
tool for many businesses
instead of running their own servers to
house their data or provide computing
power companies can buy that storage as
they need it from cloud providers who
maintain massive server centers
this was true before the pandemic but
the last two years have seen a big
uptick in the use of cloud computing
and three big companies now dominate the
market
amazon google and microsoft so how did
they cement their grip on the cloud
business
and what does it mean for their
customers and for their competitors
joining me to discuss this is wsj
enterprise tech reporter aaron tilley hi
erin thanks for coming on the show
thanks for having me
so we know that the big three players in
this field amazon microsoft and google
were dominant before the pandemic but
they've gotten bigger over the last few
years so just how big are we talking
about and why has this happened
yeah so the uh big three cloud platforms
now account for 65
of the 53 billion global market um
that's according to synergy research
group and that's up from 52
just four years ago
so a crucial reason why we've seen this
kind of growth has really been the
pandemic
the pandemic has accelerated the shift
to the cloud a lot of businesses and
various organizations governments have
had to shift to the cloud all their
infrastructure was difficult to maintain
remotely
they didn't have people on staff
to maintain their data centers in
industry parlance that's on-prem data
center so they had to really shift
wholesale to the cloud and this is
something they had been planning but
been putting off so
the dominance really accelerated for the
big three and their growth really
maintained a massive scale through the
pandemic and coming out of that we don't
see that slowing down these sort of
migrations to the cloud seem to be
continuing at the same pace
you've spoken to some of the smaller
players in this industry though and what
do they say their challenges are to
trying to compete with these big
dominant players
yeah so the smaller players one of the
big things they're trying to do is
trying to do the best they can at the
thing they do specialization that's
their way to differentiate from the big
cloud platforms
trying to do a lot of stuff so
for example there's a new company out
called sushi cloud that's focusing on
figuring out how to sell cloud
infrastructure that will be more
optimized for running artificial
intelligence it'll be cheaper and faster
than the big three cloud giants
and there's others like
cloudflare that's offering
lower rates to send your data out of
their cloud which is a huge huge expense
on the top three cloud platforms
something called egress charges egress
fees
so a specialization is the
differentiation that they're trying to
bring to the market
that is their response to the situation
i mean obviously if you're competing in
any industry against kind of the
existing players or the dominant players
you're going to have that challenge you
know being an up-and-coming company but
are there other specific challenges to
operating in the cloud industry that
these smaller companies might face
the uh situation of
potential upcoming recession there is
going to be some corporate belt
tightening where
a lot of customers will want to
consolidate on a fewer number of
platforms to
attain some greater efficiencies less
cost and logistics of managing multiple
vendors so naturally that's going to
further consolidate onto
the sort of dominant three platforms
companies spending
one of the big three companies said in
response to the fact that they've gotten
so big during this period you know this
is a really for them a very positive
story where these three cloud giants the
cloud is really a success story for all
of them whereas they might be facing
issues like supply chain or declining
digital ad markets
the cloud is their growth story for
investors and so
for them to continue to see growth at
this scale for their cloud business is
great news and they're competing really
aggressively against each other which
ends up usually really lowering prices
for customers you know i spoke to
customers who really appreciate the kind
of competition between the big three
that this naturally this is all kind of
lowering prices for them so
for them it's all great
yeah let's talk about the customer side
a little bit because you know you
mentioned it's lowering costs for them
are customers at all concerned though
that they have limited choices in this
sector
for sure i think especially in other
countries
we see in europe there is a growing
concern that all their data all their
information how their digital market
works it's all going to these three u.s
cloud giants and i think there is an
escalating concern around that kind of
situation
so we're seeing an urgent pushback in
europe we're seeing some customers get
savvy and how they manage between these
three cloud giants big cloud customers
like walmart what they're doing is that
they're also
furthering their investment in their own
data center infrastructure they have
these things they call edge networks
they're essentially servers in their own
retail stores and and distribution
centers so they continue to invest in
their own infrastructure meanwhile
they're managing
between google and microsoft and this is
a way for them to kind of attain
independence from the cloud giants
i mean the other thing that i wonder if
there's any pushback on or any concern
within these companies is that having
more dominance in the cloud sector is
coming at a time when they're also under
scrutiny for having dominance
in other areas i mean all of these
companies are under some kind of
anti-trust eye from regulators so are
they concerned that they're getting too
big in this sector as well
i think that is a serious concern we
haven't heard much from regulators on
this front especially in the u.s you
know a lot of the sort of tech
backlash that we've seen throughout the
world has been focused like on social
media social media issues disinformation
mobile app stores
but there is a
i think growing set of concerns in the
cloud and we see that again especially
in europe in europe there have been at
least three anti-trust complaints lodged
against microsoft for
the way their cloud business has been
run so we're seeing inklings of this
emerge throughout the world
all right that was our reporter aaron
tilly thanks so much for joining us erin
thanks for having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you